how's that all encoded
in the brain like where's the storage of
information are we talking
just maybe to get it uh a little bit
more specific
is it in the hardware of the actual
connections is it
in chemical communication is it
electrical communication
do we do we know so this is you know a
paper that we are bringing out
soon which ones um this is the cortical
micro circuits paper that
i sent you a draft of of course this is
uh a lot of it is still hypothesis one
hypothesis is that
a you can think of a cortical column as
encoding
a a concept a concept you know think of
it as a
uh a um an example of a concept is
um is an edge present or not or is
is an object present or not okay so it
can you can think of it as a binary
variable a binary random variable
the presence of an edge or not or the
presence of an object or not
so each cortical column can be thought
of as representing
that one concept one variable and then
the connections between these cortical
columns are
basically encoding the relationship
between these random variables
and then there are connections within
the cortical column there are
each cortical column is implemented
using multiple layers of neurons
with very very very rich um
structure there you know there are
thousands of neurons in a cortical
column
but but that structure is similar across
the different cortical columns
yeah correct and also these cortical
columns collect connect to a
substructure called thalamus
in the you know so all cortical columns
pass through this substructure so our
hypothesis
is that yeah the connections between the
cortical columns
implement this uh you know that's where
the knowledge is stored
about you know how these different
connect concepts connect to each other
and then the the neurons inside this
cortical column and in the thalamus in
combination
implement this uh actual computation
centered for
inference which includes explaining away
and competing between the different uh
hypotheses um and it is all very
so what is amazing is that uh
neuroscientists have
actually done experiments to the tune of
showing these things uh they might not
be putting it in the
overall inference framework but they
will show things like
if i poke this higher level neuron uh it
will inhibit
through this complicated loop through
the thalamus it will inhibit this other
column
uh so they will do such experiments
right but do they use
terminology of concepts for example so
so you
you're i mean is it
uh is it something where it's easy to
anthropomorphize
and think about concepts like you start
moving into
logic based kind of reasoning systems so
um i would just think of concepts in
that kind of way
or is it is it a lot messier
a lot more gray area you know
even even more gray even more messy than
uh
are the artificial neural network kinds
of abstractions
easiest way to think of it as a variable
right it's a binary variable
which is showing the presence or absence
of
something but i guess what i'm asking is
is that something
uh that we're supposed to think of
something that's human interpretable
of that something it doesn't need to be
it doesn't need to be human
interpretable there is no need for it to
be human interpretable uh
but it's it's almost like um
you you will be able to find some
interpretation of it
uh because it is connected to the other
things
yes that you know and the the point is
it's useful
somehow yeah it's useful as an entity
in the graph that in connecting to the
other entities that are
let's call them concepts right okay so
uh by the way what's
are these the cortical micro circuits
correct these are the cortical micro
circuits
you know that's what neuroscientists use
to talk about
the circuits in in within a level of the
cortex
so you can think of you know let's think
of a neural
network in artificial neural network
terms you know people talk about the
architecture of the you know so
how many how many layers they build uh
you know what is the fan in fan out
etcetera
that is the macro architecture so
and then within a layer of the neural
network
you can you know the cortical neural
network
is much more structured with you know
within a level there's a lot more
intricate structure there uh but even um
even within an artificial neural network
you can think of in feature detection
plus pooling as one
one level and so that is kind of a micro
circuit
uh it's much more complex in the real
brain
and and so within a level whatever is
that circuitry within a column
of the cortex and between the layers of
the cortex that's the micro circuitry
i love that terminology machine learning
people don't use
the circuit terminology but they should
you